well welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
one two three look at me I can't hear my
beautiful voice
why can't you hear you probably turned
down how did you do that on purpose on
purpose more very exciting if you don't
know I thought we're doing a totally
deaf good pointing at me like I would do
it your fault
turn your headphone carbon well there
are abyss with those okay there there
that is okay we're doing the podcast
live breasts Falls Beach Florida
I like at the West Palm improv well
Kerry palms the August 23rd it's going
to be awesome
it is getting full just so people know
we will be meeting everyone after the
show people have asked us that I didn't
say anything about that well I will be
well I'm the personality champ actually
I probably should no way you can really
make a determination for yourself with
your essay so for example can't you it
anyways yeah personality chance make
sure you you get your tickets also the
Irvine improv we're doing your mom's
house live October 8th it's going to go
down don't sweat it
this is the one we've rescheduled if you
did have tickets to the last one they
did not transfer that's something we
just found out and the reason that they
didn't transfer is because they're dumb
but Wow Wow wouldn't you do that so
pretty sensible I don't know they
refunded people and you just have to
rebuy them not check they're doing so
October 8th Irvine improv your mom's
house live I'm shooting a special
Timber 16th in denver the first show is
sold out the second show has about a
hundred and fifty tickets left so if you
want to go this is probably the last
week they'll be available a couple shows
that have been added just so you know
I'm doing the Brea improv for one night
September 13 so that's two nights or
three nights before I shoot this special
I'm doing the Fox Theater in Oakland two
nights before the special and the week
before I'm in Nebraska
Midwest City and Springfield Missouri
all leading up to the special after that
the my tour continues if you go to Tom
Segura comm slash tour you can see all
the dates there Toronto and Arbor
Indianapolis it just goes on and on of
course New York City is now on sale do
dork titties
I always feel it necessary to explain to
the Toronto people that because of the
way that the festival set up the link
when you go to my page if you go to
violet Toronto ticket and you hit like
fine tickets it finds you a festival
pass
you actually have to scroll down and go
headliner ticket and that's the visual
ticket to my show it's just really
annoying so I've had to explain people
on Instagram and on Twitter you know a
hundred times how to do that
it's just something they didn't really
think through this song by the way is
easy produced by Chris rhythm about that
present for them yeah said Nebraska I'm
thinking nerd braska yes yeah I know
there's a better one out there but nerd
brass their breasts go okay dude that
was horrible you have no idea what you
just did to people that was horrible why
would you do that into them that was
horrible I've never done it before
almost wanted to try and completely blew
it out say I'm sorry I just wanted to
see what that felt like
huh I'm never wrong mom mom mom why did
you do
to me I've never sneezed on this show
million people just ask that question no
sorry I love you were you going to be
all right
hog tips with you the 23rd and west palm
parry palm bitch September 22nd 23 st.
lous tips mom Zuri at hiriam comedy krub
and then October 3rd Nashville NAB's
Ville Tennessee that's good nadz Ville
Tennessee the babies babies come on you
clubs look good
October 4th Charlotte North Carolina
grew its course it's Charlotte the
comedy zone and then October 8th I'm
with you doing ymh live in sperm violet
is Charlotte a one-nighter yeah Bokke
yeah October 4 it okay is that okay with
you yeah words tickets are now at
Cristina P online.com hard you can still
do thousand ranch that's still good too
and I did get gold see Christina do a
stand-up ship now we're talking come on
did what you trying to do to me excited
that's my special of my specialist hi oh
my special do you like big tits yeah
show me hollows big tits part the good
night unless you purples you were voting
for mushy purple I was hard loading yeah
stage into the managers don't like that
one no I like it a lot do like big dude
they're like big feet you like it did
great man okay right good all right oh I
added a second show in fart go I'm going
to fart go where they filming TV show
it's your favorite show I know that I'm
going to do it I added a second show
there so I just let people know is that
in North Dakota yeah I guess you know
that Wow yeah yeah all I know is like
it's definitely not LA so I don't have
to care there you go I did I don't want
to be knowledgeable the work good
attitude good attitude you did Amazon
right I thought I didn't do Mama's on
please shop through our amazon banner
it's very easy to do all you do is go to
your mom's house podcast calm you do the
shopping you would normally
do on Amazon after you click our banner
it gives a little kick back to the show
we also have a UK version and we have a
Canadian version Canadia
in Canadian my first play is in Canadia
you can shop through our amazon.ca
banner and it supports the show
Canada's not LA but I still like it it's
your birthplace right Ontario Windsor
broad ones are native now you brought me
out in Toronto was really funny I did
yeah you go proud Windsor native and I
was wearing the Canadian tuxedo on that
show yeah I was really fun I was a lot
of fun it's always fun to do Canadia I
actually am most looking forward if I
could be honest I'm really looking
forward to shooting the special and I
used spill on your big test and I'm
looking forward to shooting the special
obviously in Denver but I hope for the
rest of year I think I'm most looking
forward to my Toronto date is that right
yeah TDOT is an amazing city I called I
called that I coined that phrase TDOT
and now they call destiny it's
embarrassing
alright here we go well why don't you
say that all the places on your
calendars are places you want to go to I
like doing that or great place I'm
saying a most I love the City of Toronto
yeah I do do it's going to be exciting
for me and my cousin brie Brie might
come oh you're kidding yeah if is there
food in Toronto oh my god he's gonna ask
what I think the food's out my turn and
would you know what time you're checking
in and then do you know what are you
going to go downstairs now is it should
I go with the is organized and I hate
that again at his seat can I I also do
and then after do you want me to be
there and then how are you getting to
the airport which has a decade where you
think you're going to get something good
do you think the food's too spicy in
Toronto or will they have items on the
menu that don't have spice I have to
wash my hands after cause I know when I
get spice in my cat's eyes when I paddle
I can also do enzymes to break down all
that spice that's true you know my
parents were the opposite of your
parents like whereas your parents
explain things to you and they were like
they take the time my family there was
do not ask questions policy yeah it was
always like don't ask just don't ask so
I learn
to be very self-reliant that way yeah I
don't have questions anymore all right
here we go
I go take a big stinking shit after I go
I don't use 24 across the toilet I fit
my hand I get in here get three three
roughly and flush again dip on the
thirty four five who is Randy don't
bring anyone love into this I'm gonna
focus bad
well welcome welcome to your boss
[Music]
we were make sure when they came out to
ball Sacramento this weekend the full
charge was with me always fantastic
always fantastic we were hanging out and
randomly we heard two Guns and Roses
songs just like addresses up and we're
talking about like you imagine what it
was like in their heyday to be slash and
I got on stage during one of those solos
and your face is melting off from the
drugs you did backstage and you're just
like you don't have to think to play
your solo and it's a stadium
it's like 80,000 people just going like
and you're so fucking high you know and
the energy and like it's so crazy they
tried to tell you when when the show's
over that I came in it's over now
she's like yeah what yeah he was saying
full-charge said he read Slash's book
yeah and that you know they used to get
so fucked up to tricking handles of Jack
and doing heroin
I'm the guy that he one time he called
somebody in a hotel he was like where
are we and there you know where are we
they were in Tokyo they just shut the
fuck up and we go look out the window he
looked out the winner he's like I should
his Toki he had no idea where he was omg
omg serious plan those hot licks doing
on the road is that what they call those
hot licks I really guitars the hot lick
I think such a dad word could you
imagine also the rate at which those
guys were probably getting laid - no no
there ought to come there's no cousin
right there's no coming and even that
guy / I wasn't a huge I was just not a
huge fan of those dudes
I don't listening to Bauhaus and you
know whatever but yeah
his face was totally covered with hair
right the Hat was like hero on the eye
again I got in the bridge of your nose
yeah and the hair covers the face and
the cigarette was just hanging out of
his mouth I mean he just looked fucked
up constantly yeah I don't know if he
was but he definitely looked that way
but he could shred right you are talent
I just remember I was joking I remember
that you know people would always talk
about
guitar players and I'm not a guitar
player but I would always hear the
conversations about the greatest and it
would always be you know people would
talk about BB King Eric Clapton always
people and Hendrix but I remember when
at least when I was listening to those
songs at first I would be like is this
not a bad motherfucker because sounds
like it to me the way that those solos
hotlinks got plays how ways were shred
apart man I mean he really did them
again he destroyed them they are an
amazing band like look nobody I mean
very few people didn't like that man
like you I was god like hardcore gods
and I knew all their songs because
they'd play them like in grocery stores
and shit and they definitely hold up
first sure ons are well you could put it
on it's it's a song did you have them
did you have a GNR shirt I mean I wasn't
I wasn't a gr shirt guy but I definitely
had those I had the tape because that's
still like one of the best
I remember for a football it was it was
one of the pregame tapes they play on
the overhead since I am a jungle yeah
and and and also in the weight room so
whenever we had I mean that came out it
still comes on you're like fucking he
upon through this yeah you ready to
crack some fuckin skulls when you hear
that music definitely welcome to the
jungle
yeah I remember heard you do that voice
I never want to hear it and what it was
it as good as my sneeze earlier or worse
like what was more terrible yeah his
that's a person Axl Rose's voice is also
so crazy crazy amazed do you think he
still can sing like that he's old no I
don't think you can sing just like that
but I think it's probably pretty good
man because there is there is such thing
as after a certain point there's certain
voices that just you can't watch right
Harry can't hit the note she used we
could mean Whitney couldn't I don't
think Aretha Franklin can hit the notes
she hit in the 70s like it's just like
you know MJ - you know yeah thank you
age I like Perry Pharrell's voice a lot
from James a DJ and rape voice he's
another one that I don't think it sounds
like anybody else
it's amaze it's super unique it's true
yeah it's a weird one but Axl's was like
so famous Axl and nobody if somebody
else like there's songs where another
singer can sing the song I guess that's
that song but if someone else sings guns
roses songs it doesn't say you can't do
that yeah no that's a special unique
thing a group of people in the space and
time and place and everything can't
replicate now because I grew up in Reno
as I grew up in LA and I remember when
that band hit GNR because they were like
a Sunset Strip bad it was fuckin
pandemonium dude was it like because I
used to go to the Roxy my stepmom liked
of all things Hessian music like heavy
metal heavy metal is huge when those
guys came out so we would go down to the
Roxy and see bands playing that they
were just the biggest thing man those
guys you couldn't escape them did you
see them play in a small venue I don't
think so
no no but I remember pirate radio was a
singing la with Hessian radio station
and they played them it was a big scene
here it must have been so crazy to be
like oh yeah I saw Guns and Roses a
troubadour and yeah I met and then the
next year we're just seeing other Dodger
Stadium right now yeah well our friend
Alan who does her hair he's like yeah I
was looking dude addiction on something
my clicking GNR he so he's a little bit
older than I said yeah oh that's not all
that should he probably party all for
sure
yeah in also these are the Pixies Megan
maybe six
that's not he looks good for his age
doesn't he I start to pay attention to
that so much more now yeah I saw
something like some guy died and it was
on his bio him to such 53 and like it's
good does dude looks 80 yeah there's
people who just you know look you're
lucky because your pops he looks great
you look fantastic
yeah 71 looks great my mother actually
aged very well too yeah we'll see what
happens here
bye mama yeah I think they both looks
okay you're set up for success now this
actually means it's all on you so I'm
like ready yeah yeah
stay off the heroin yeah yeah now you
see it all I mean I'm talking to people
now how are you and then you know yeah
Rogan just turned 50 I think Hey look he
looks amazing it's great really taking
air and salt alright so that is the key
this is an age where you can look 40 or
you can look 90 like 50 was like oh
really
it
you follow one side or the other oh yeah
well 40 is when you hit a wall
but that's when you either you go hard
on maintenance no I'm in my third man
like thinking about what would be my
shoutout I just don't I hate you so much
how much more until you're 40 I don't
know I can't add that high it's still a
while what's going to happen tomorrow
what's it like up there actually I was
already thinking to how next year I
thought it won't turn 40 will that be
like I don't know hate you so bad I like
bringing my four I like 41 it's awesome
it's fucking great because you know give
a fuck I didn't give a fuck in my 30s
now I give even less fucks in my 40s
yeah
you just fucking don't care I do like
that process of living and aging yeah I
did people know realize it really
happens where as the years go by you
really are like well yeah every years a
little more it's not that you don't care
about everything you know that you care
about certain things and then the rest
just right you realize weird how
insignificant and not important things
are yeah exactly it's just like we know
when you're in middle school you care so
much about oh my god when that person
think if I wear these brown shoes yeah
you think it's so important and you you
make sure that like you you don't have
those shoes on like you think that
someone else is focused you know and I
know 20 30 years later you're like oh no
don't be like a foot shit of shit into
like something to decaying what I wore
now and not to be a shameless plug or
right now but on that see bro that is a
lot of what I talk about on that show
about life and the nature of it again
and part of getting your life to is like
you you learn to focus your Fox really
it's like that little art of knocking
fuck and I talk about that book a lot I
love it it's funny because I I bought
this book reading it and then I go
you're gonna love it yeah
and then you're like oh my god I wanna
how la la la I really a five-hour I'm
not super all-time I love your voice I
love the your Girl Talk voice that's
because I hear you speak oh that is not
how I talked about how your sisters talk
no it's not it's exactly I'm sorry oMG
Miranda LaBelle ha ha your boyfriend
here I love you
a big stinky shit after I go I don't use
24 a question toilet my Hannah get in
here yeah three three right-handers
flush again one is it equal I'm so now
you want describe his his gear yeah so
let's say he's on the non-binary
spectrum yeah I mean the shirt is torn
open sharing so that half of his chest
is written etic torn shirt and it says
sexy vegan and then vegan on me we all
know that he's vegan do the tattooed or
it's written in humongous permanent
marker and then it's over the I own the
other Florian I'm vegan on his eyebrows
yeah and he's got like there's one of
those gauges or something in the air and
yeah it looks like then a blue tooth or
something in this looks lean he's
definitely being in yes definitely eats
right now we know so he doesn't use
paper but I thought this was interesting
listen to his and I did and I go deep
into a lifetime keeping ruffle plush
time and again 100 times crush this
[Music]
first of all I want to point out that
you know he's big on obviously not using
the paper
he's already flushed three or four times
so he's wasting water water Todd oh he's
trading to paper ways for water trees
for the water yeah I mean yes people say
that's gross but the fact remains that
clean last week for three records about
some other science it's not there's no
points no I never else but you could
smell from like at least put away like
you go like Roger you think it's not
mine you can my smells delicious wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute did
you just see what I saw the eyebrows
what there are no eyebrows they're
shaved and penciled their markered in
like that crazy guy that used to live in
the rampart division at the bus stop are
you suggesting that this guy's not
mentally fit
what's going on these vegan Jersey you
can vagina city they love to identify
vegans can't shut the fuck up about it
that's the anova that's one lane of it
but this is also like a little crazy and
then it's become an identity like when
the diet becomes an identity and look I
get it it's attendant I'm licking your
balls or your penis or something go
ahead go ahead you can pretend you can
pretend they're permission
this would fucking hate that guy no I
don't I don't want to put out there that
I do not hate vegans I don't I just
think when you identify with any diet so
much you have to advertise it it's a
little weird she's really into it he
goes deep in his hole with his bare
hands hold on jumped over that we got
our wife his ass with his bare hand in
the toilet water and it goes deep and
his asshole well I mean let me tell you
why I'm not so opposed to it because the
tushy and the bidet
use the toilet water that's in the tank
we're using his hand no gene right but
it's all it's all fun I'm not on the
same okay you know well yeah but you use
okay listen you use your hand to wash
your asshole in the shower okay Barry
you don't use a water than shit when I
do it it's not a shitty asshole it's
already the most very clean bottle and
I'm just trying to get him the benefit
of the doubt that's all I used to in
Harold
toilet paper to have to go on just gets
away from notice where the papers live
in my house Orin himself
you don't like it don't don't hit you on
the way young no soap - now wait a
minute that's just not sanitary you came
to China because he's going to get the
poopie on his hands on oh yeah you need
soap buddy no he's not into it at all
why not the soap that's the vegan
there's vegan soap there's got to be
vegan that's quite like dr. Bronner's or
whatever that hippie soap in hoses no no
man there's got to be vegan soap um
those guys he's really he's big on
pushing his uh he goes you don't like it
there's no toilet paper there's no soap
don't let the door hit you on the way
out ah yeah but problems without in the
past
actually there's a lack of people
visiting his home is my guess I don't
think that there's a lot of visitors at
all you know no I think when they go hey
did you shave your eyebrows and write
vegan on your forehead then they go
maybe I won't come over actually I think
that happen now the thing is that he's a
fairly attractive human he's not like
the other animal and he's got a clean
asshole he said dozen yeah but he
doesn't use soap on it so how clean can
it be he said it doesn't smell
I trust him I don't trust him mother I
don't trust you need soap hey do you
want to hear some good news
antiseptic so much horrible news these
days oh my god there's some good news
the chubby chaser took our advice
remember that girl yeah she wrote in
yeah how do I go she writes hello Jean I
wrote to you about a month ago asking
advice on how to approach a chubby guy I
was interested in I just wanted to give
you a follow-up I took your advice and
happy to say it worked out I made the
first move like you suggested and we
went out last weekend all your
suggestions about reassert reassert
reassurance and physicality were spot on
as he seemed to loosen up as the night
went on I also went out of my way to
make sure that night would be my cheat
day so I didn't come up with a stuck-up
bitch food snob okay we have plans this
weekend again and I can't wait to get to
know him better would he ever date his
mom does he like moose soup maybe he
loves watching studio G clips guess
we'll find out
thanks again Hitler your adoring fart
mistress Britney how about that that's
fantastic yeah I'm shocked you guys are
doing good glad to hear it that's so
excite
good for you I hope you guys get along I
hope it's a long term mommy yeah if you
find your genes I hope you do it's
really great really great everybody
finds their genes mm-hmm you know what's
interesting last night we were watching
billions we were in bed so obsessed with
this right now it's okay it's just good
entertainment that's what it is I was
thinking about everything is over
analysed these days you know of meaning
I feel the same way about stand-up what
is a message where as you're trying to
say and then you're like it's just funny
like this show is just entertaining it's
just good entertainment it is good
guys got the weird mouth the lead
character but I like him like that and
the white his odors in it the comedian
comedian he's great
I love the therapist character I love
his wife character she's she's a real
fucking old school neighborhood crazy I
like that
and so this episode we watched last
night season two they introduced a
non-binary character did non-binary out
to other people who have been like yeah
we were watching this show for months I
know but we started we always we might
start on walking dead soon yeah maybe
Game of Thrones
maybe Sopranos will get into the wire I
heard today we're going to try that soon
yeah good stuff but it was just good
they you look I like this act act
Russian I don't know what to say I can't
I call them an actor mm-hmm where's an
actress no shattered factor okay I like
them I've seen them because they are
really non-binary they really are and
I've seen them on orange is the new
black pronoun they they are fantastic in
that mmm but it is cool it was
interesting to see how they they don't
really address it dance odors character
is like oh I ordered you lunch I assumed
you were vegan and hilarious and really
funny scene yeah and then they go like
eventually yes they are done which is
funny course on vegan of course I mean
India and they do do a good job with
somebody else's like well she knew what
she was talking about he's like they oh
I didn't do it
oh you met me where you must have fall
asleep yeah is they and then the person
is goes like alright and whatever not
sure but before that so we were
snuggling in bed the dogs and everything
and I wore a nice night yawn I thought
it would be kind of special roof so you
know anyways we're smuggling and then
you farted one and I let that one go I
let slide I was like well we go fool me
once and then the second fart
rolled around
why do you have to make eye contact with
me when you play that drop we work on
making music here together the contact I
was kind of playing this sounds like
when we read our but our kid those sound
books yours you're reading the text and
I'm pushing the button yeah it was so
and then I got up and I left because it
was offensive the second one was so
stinky and you really pushed it wasn't
like an oopsie it was deliberate and I
felt like he wanted me to smell and get
him sorry but it occurred to me that
because I've been smelling your farts
for 12 years now that I could probably
get guess your farts and a line up yeah
Lee if there were I don't really want to
get that experiment going going though I
don't know if you want to ask like how
about you guys you five guys fart here
and I'll stand behind this door and then
here's what we can do now I did these
experiments in college where I had a
roommate that would fart into film
containers and seal the container and
then send the fart across the country
well I nobody would open it and we could
smell the fart and did you guys do that
too uh my old roommate Kevin and he
would mail fart to like his friends back
home in Seattle and they would know it
huh yeah and it works yeah they mailed
me a fart once when I was studying in
England and I got a fart mail to me and
it does work they mailed me a fart from
the states
Shana and Kevin yeah Wow yeah neat I
mean I'm just saying that's one way we
can do the experiment is that difficult
a mail someone a fart like that has it
open it may just vomit because it says
it because you have guard really weird
yeah I mean I knew what it was because
we done it as roommates like you talk in
the house yeah they really does stay in
there it does an overseas I mean that
traveled from the u.s. to England
unbelievable really very impressive
now the key the struggle today would be
to find the film container because I
know it's a lot of them you know of
course I guy Amazon we can get a bunch
of time you're the photo the photo lab
that I went to they have to has to be
airtight you could ask them you know you
could do going to you guys have any
discarded
film canisters good for like sealing
farts and see if they're like uh yeah
Nunez works yes we sell these over here
for real and parts of people Irish I
mean you have to admit that it's a
pretty amazing discovery like my own
roommate Kevin discovered it randomly
yeah and it is pretty revolutionary if
you think about it how else would you
mail a fart no it's incredible it's
incredible how else could you send this
Mel you could put it in one of those
mason jars there with the Guru
especially with the seal you know that
kind we're gonna pull the lever so to
seal it
I know my talking about yeah decorative
yeah now are those airtight yeah now now
here's my thinking
the scientists listening can verify or
not the reason the film canister works
so well is because you have less volume
in there yeah there's less air so really
preserves the essence of the fart now my
thinking is amazing jar can be very
large and maybe you're going to dilute
the smell mmm with all the air molecules
I have to point this out it's just I
just remember I don't want to forget
paternal twins means identical twins see
now I the last week we were talking
about it we got some messages oh yeah I
looked it up and it's not commonly
referred to as paternal know I know what
fraternal or identical but they're
technically retinal is identical is
identical it's into two right right the
same egg right so but I was making that
point that when we were trying to figure
out what that meant it's been clarified
okay and yeah somebody wrote identical
dicks are important hey Hitler mommies I
just wanted to share a story about twin
penises with you I just had a Hawaiian
family move in across the street from me
the father invited me over to have a few
beers with him he has twin sons and in
the middle of our conversation he said I
hope they have the same sized dick or
else one is going to steal the other
ones girlfriend due to having a larger
penis my jaw dropped earlier that day
you guys were having the very important
question about twin dicks sorry this
doesn't answer the question but it
important we find out the answer love
always your bali your poly by slipper
guy Wow deductr well this is one of
those mysteries that we're going to
continue exploring our never stops never
stop searching Nigel justice is served
you see that dick detectives graphic
someone made I did not you didn't see
the hell oh my god it's so fucking
phenomenal I'm going to send it it looks
it smell send this smell here I'll pull
up on the screen so just give me a
second in the meantime Tom we've been
getting a little pushback on the topic
very popular dear to our hearts you know
Danielle does Olli we know that she
changed today as a DS
on Twitter okay Danielle yeah she writes
hey Christina P Tom Segura I know this
is an inflammatory statement but I've
been thinking about it farts do push the
shit out oh we're going there again huh
I mean it's thought-provoking and let's
reopen the topic well what's the
explanation I mean we had a great
explanation for the other four little
shits push the fart out right so why is
she saying that the opposite does she
tell you feels that way really no case
it's a failing argument I mean the other
person really laid out that we had it
wrong this whole time and you're saying
that someone said no it's the other way
but there's no way she said she's been
thinking about I guess what she's saying
is intuitively it feels as though fart
push the shit as opposed to shits
pushing before counterintuitive that
should put push the fart out it's
counterintuitive not logical no it is
logical but I feel it the fresh new push
to shit no but then how do you shit okay
think about it here's the thing here in
my case Jana is that how do I know I
have to shit in the morning the farts
are coming because the shits are pushing
the fart site but the farts are also
simultaneously pushing the shit out oh
no but then I can't fart without the I
can't shit without the fart okay okay
what I think we'll have to table this
how do you agree to disagree
yeah we'll wait a little bit longer on
this Bob Brown but thank you for
supporting the store there's all these
uh we have the DJ dad mouth - black
shirt people ask for that shirt in black
the rub rub shirt obvious nobody likes
that goes up Kane has a new shirt
Big Daddy Kane and I did together
[Music]
anyways and there's new soup there's a
to MU soup shirt so thanks for everyone
I always want to say thank you for for
getting them and hope you you like the
stuff hold on I have to fart I dream
like you know what maybe should to push
the fart job because I can fart
without having to shoes I think like
that I think we're all good now I think
we've covered all your thoughts and
opinions on this and no but think about
it if I can fart without having to shit
yeah then it truly is that shit's push
the fart out yeah farts don't have to
push the shit out this is what I wanted
to show you look just the dick
detectives fat head comics Wow there's
nothing that is amazing
my characters outline dick that's so
good a dick here in the dicta times
great it's really funny that's really
funny
fat head comics on Instagram and Twitter
thank you very much for the dick
detectives graphic dome yeah it's really
great but cool really impressed do you
want to hear some emails about deaf
people yeah okay so last time you know
the problem is fucking OtterBox
we asked how blind people know the deaf
people are blind people how they wake up
definitely o'clock this person writes in
Brigitte my college roommate was not
deaf but would sleep through any alarm
she bought an alarm made for deaf people
it was a mat that slid under her
mattress and would shake her whole bed
at the say at the set time I've always
wondered about that's really interesting
there are people out there that cannot
wake up isn't that amazing
and
now I'm my buddy Steve in high school we
you know what would crash at each
other's places all the time and the
alarm could be next to his head Oh blast
and I would be like I just look at this
do like and you just go start shaking
them sleeps right through it I don't
understand I'm he attached trying I
don't think so
he's slow no I just got a big head yeah
I know people like that I hate people
like that I know in labor not like I
pick him up like a Saturday morning we'd
have you know they have to make you go
to practice sometimes on Saturday so I
Drive over to his place I'm pounding on
the door that's next to his bedroom
pound pound pen and I could hear the
alarm through the door so annoying
Jane by the way my younger sister if she
falls asleep on the couch at midnight
and you're like I'll go to bed you can
you can take her you could drag her off
the couch leave her head hanging on the
couch her legs are on the couch still
would wake up you can push her you can
smack her in the face
nothing so crazy I don't understand how
you could sleep that deeply I guess
their neurological maybe there they shut
down so completely more so than you know
other people I don't know yeah but I
heard about us once we started asking
people have come up to me at even at
those shows and they said about shaking
bed okay well here's another one
we asked oh no no the derivative really
another thing is people deaf people use
flashing lights a doorbell ring would be
a quick dingdong or an on/off succession
of flashing lights and a baby crying
would be rapidly blinking lights to
indicate Wow
so like how do they get around the house
and do your bells they're not like that
they use make sense yeah I guess you
have to have those lights in the room
obviously that you're in right yeah yes
yes of course yeah so did you put them
everywhere I guess so I guess so or the
whole house must blink I don't know yeah
it's a shot of me anyway here's another
very thought-provoking question about
blind people that you're going in okay
Corey from Jew dork titties right sin
hey
how do blind people find the Braille
signage in public places
mmm no shit right yeah yeah how the fuck
did they find it that's interesting yeah
yeah damn it I mean sometimes it makes
obvious sense like ATM yeah because
you're you're finding out where is the
ATM and you know you you're directed
towards it by somebody and then once you
get there you can read the Braille but I
don't know I mean that's it's
interesting right yeah I guess your
guide then maybe have a guy and the
guide is like I told you this is where
you go about the the time I was in it
was in New York and they're in jus dork
titties uh-huh and there was a blind guy
across the street going like this waving
his hand over his head and he started to
do it more and more aggressively and I
guess what it what he was doing was he
was signaling that he needed somebody to
walk him across the street he wasn't he
wasn't nice about it at all so when I
went up something is god damn it they're
doing it for ten fucking minutes oh and
then like I walked across the street
with him you know I got and then like
when we got to the other side
he didn't say like thanks motherfucker
and he just kept walking because I think
that light didn't have the flu
yeah so he just stood there and but I
was like I mean I I was hesitant to
approach I don't know what this fucking
guy yeah why is this crazy person waving
he wouldn't know and that sounds waiting
waiting for someone to help him
oh yeah did you give him a rub rub rub
to think you know him said you owe me
kiss you on the peanuts or anything like
that it was like yeah because I've been
waiting for for ten minutes yet to
sharpen the knife yeah - yeah so you
have to do sometimes you know I was at
the comedy store this weekend and I took
pictures of people robbed and I was
talking to fans in the hallway you know
people who listen to show everybody was
like Congress Tina you are the
personality champ because where's Tom
right now he's not even at the Comedy
Store taking pictures
you just absolutely sealed your fate
because hundreds of people in punchline
Sacramento were like I'll tell you one
thing Cena didn't meet us after this
show you know and you want to know
something I'll be 100% honest here the
reason I did not yeah they have metal
detectors for people going in so I was
like I'm kind of scared honestly and I
don't think that our fans are you know
gun wielding lunatics but I was like if
they're fucking making these people go
through metal detectors I mean you know
I never got it yeah little I don't know
but I still I was spooked you were
spooked you know been really I swear
Sactown huh I swear I had a guy walked
by me and he had that midday drunk swag
you know he was like I could see him
walking up and he was like I could see
who's like talking shit to nobody you
know shit
you know how alcohol will give you a
little more yeah he was like my buddy
shit
and then as he walked by me he was like
I was born in this city and I'll put my
foot up your motherfucking ass I was
like okay and as he walked by me he
turned around he goes come and do it
theater near you like this dude that
means that's serious that's like an
old-school thing to say to you know
coming yeah I got a 20 year old yeah
like he said that by the club no by the
back down the mattress store uh-huh not
by the mattress store that location is
weird
that's what I'm saying and that's
another reason I'm kind of like where do
me people yeah because I don't like to
locate the mattress store is weird
also I had a lot of weird experiences in
the hotel and I feel like there was a
lot of just zombies weirdos around I was
like I don't know so weird area but it's
a show you should feel alright man I
said I trust your mom's house fans but
there were other people at the show not
just mommies you know I can always weird
love ogres don't stab me your subject
okay I didn't know you I mean it's
different being a woman I guess hell
yeah there's also different having a
super sour personality what you do you
know so maybe that was it I don't have a
sour personality don't you do a hairball
yeah you do look who's fun first of all
I'm fully hydrated I have to Fiji waters
super fun apps fun Guatemala mug that
our nanny got us and he got me because
I'm fine I like to have fun
where's your fun Guatemala mug I don't
have a fungal enema she didn't get you
one because she knows that your
personality doesn't appreciate fun
suddenly that's why oh my god I have an
update on bitsy so she's been dragging
her ass scooting scooting scooting and
we took her and they checked her anal
glands she's been on antibiotics
everything and turns out today she's got
a little rash II uncle vova on her vulva
so now we have to put cream on our dog's
vulva three times a day and she's
wearing a cone so she can't lick it poor
old she's taking three different
antibiotics just to make sure we kill
whatever it is it's bothering her vag we
have to put the cream on our dog's badge
three times a day and draggin a little
box of rain out and now she keeps trying
to lick on it and she can't because the
cones on yeah a lot of gypsies got mad
at Tom Segura said the word gypsy on
television I didn't know gypsies had
time to watch TV
between pickpocketing and scamming
society all right it's true it is true
yeah yeah I said gypsy on Conan you will
you said to guide I said see guy but
then I translated you know I said I've
been teaching my son what my wife
teaches me
Jigen men a little hot tea again and I
say you know yes No
rotten gypsy and whatever it was just
like a throw away to set up the song the
Hungarian song yeah first of all
Hungarians you were right you're like
you're going to have Hungarians come out
now yeah I love action movies like I
judge her so I understand what you said
you understand what I said Conan
oh you're Hungarian and I go Mitchie
nice he goes on I got good like some
bows man he's all and his friends are
like what are you saying what he's
saying is not nice I'm golden you did I
get you didn't really get you didn't
well I should say my good you look like
a rock writer yeah they are hardcore
hardcore guys you 20 Hungarians are very
very stoked to be Hungarian yeah because
there's like five of us on the planet
yeah so we're very proud
of it yeah nobody who's on garyun also
it's about if we're Hungarian or from
that part of the world and you're here
right because obviously it's crazy this
is this is a long way from home so I
would I mean it makes sense if you're
like oh are you Bulgarians me too I got
something to get excited about you know
and now the way nyan Romanian those are
all things that you know for Adam
Sylvain and they're very small community
yeah you don't see that much just you
know I'm a hundred percent genetically
Hungarian like all the way through the
tree we did that whatever genetic
testing is yeah like I go back to the
whatever paleo from the edge it was the
big tip Patrol
you definitely my tits are big all the
way back generation generations attest
there was a the whole all the map of the
world all the region was one yeah are
all in my ancestry doing that means I'm
more that verse you are doers but it's
great that now I am responsible for
bringing my lineage to this part of the
world my parents were rather that's true
that's true well I am because I had the
son we got we have a little half hunger
boy he is totally have hung go tough
yeah yes I don't like naps I like work
Wow is your first word okay well I'd say
guide speaking of that part of the world
do you want to hear an accent it's
pretty interesting
you see if you can decipher what's being
said oh boy how you doing uh yeah uh uh
someday Cooper dasa hey I did well and I
can't hear no one here's a pair of truth
well it's not really fair because I do
think there's a little bit of
drunkenness wait with who
in medicine would this guy well it was
submitted they said you guys know
accents so well again it's also
nonsensical because he's drugged and
probably schizophrenic too I don't know
about your diagnosis I don't support it
I'm saying if he may have had a drink
yet today or is that wrong maybe the day
before he had a drink and he's just
about to enjoy a cigarette yeah that's
possible but I don't think that let's
just go back to what he's saying and not
focus on your rude diagnosis so let's
see here wait okay clearly the first
myth is how you doing how you doing yeah
I got that part
nope that part down hey you get off US
Open he said I did all hey Cooper dasu
good for nothing for nothing yeah yeah I
did pull a McAteer night whoa a wooly
McAteer next corn a wine mammoth bully
Beckett racketeering Quan oh that's a
Ruth a goddamn Roosters yeah Beirut
goddamn roosters and then I say that
someday it's a lovely day that's a good
okay lovely day excuse me I don't year
ago I was with my diesel van yeah crap
crap table he sounded like Cosby a
little wobble but it reminded me of that
amazing song remember where is it when
we did the was it the Irvine show yes
one of the songs is the vocal fry champ
but they use they use the they use the
the drunk guy I think is also Irish
she's at home
yeah it's amazing
that's a gaping dad with the vocal fry
song I have to say we have you know
every once in a while you get so much so
many replies responses and excitement
about songs that Matt Mercer song from
last week people flipped out yeah yeah
really good I realized - I was like man
I know he's made other songs for us and
he made let me see what is it that go
fry he made what it's the river song
yeah look at the river remember that one
you spit out when you heard the song the
first time he made this song
all right here we go
first I'm going over the new bridge
Arthur would off
[Music]
that's Matt Mercer also that's amazing
it was so funny oh god I dad is
ridiculous yeah hey wait a minute stop
the presses
Oh what what you have a dental update oh
my god I have the biggest dental update
but but before I even get into the
general update let me remind people now
that we're pulling out those songs every
time I log in to facebook
I'll see Facebook the police hundreds
I'm not exaggerating
hundreds of unread messages we don't do
it we don't send emails and I may go
check out the we only access things for
the show from our gmail account yeah so
if you have a song if you have a clip if
you have a story if you have a message
so far you'd want to send in a canister
all of that it's your mom's podcast at
gmail.com it is there's no house in the
email address your mom's podcast at
gmail.com I just wanted to make it clear
if you've been sending stuff on Facebook
we don't we don't check it out social
media all right so so big I can't
believe we forgot it I know
[Music]
so it's been I will say I've been pretty
good I've been pretty good lately with
dental care ah this is a I went seven
months
you know supposed to join reacts yeah so
seven months ago I had my teeth cleaned
I went back for a cleaning but I also
scheduled a in house whitening treatment
hold on before we get there how was your
report card
what was your gum score oh I was I was
just as solid as last time yeah
no exaggeration okay he's what are your
numbers let's hear that I forget I
forget what somebody I always hear 1 2 1
2 2 like I'm always really good yeah
that's what he says you're probably like
8 actually you want to true you can call
him and after this he says the best
attitude I've seen in a year
really yeah that's inaccurate because he
said that about my teeth and I was there
less than a year ago thank you very much
so I'm the teeth champions you're not my
ID they're so much better than yours if
we if we did teeth champ I'm definitely
the teeth disagree sounds really white
disagree you look like you have dog
teeth the my got my teeth are so much
better than you always have those canine
problems like canine you know that tooth
filed down all the time your teeth are
sharp and jagged like jagged tic tacs
look how white they are anyways barely
can see them though because of your big
lips and facial hair are you done go
ahead so I I went there cleaning was was
fun and fine and it wasn't fun but
painless the cleaning was that last no
problem yeah nope no blood no okay
it was I was all good when they're done
I was like I was actually pretty quick
then they go now we're going to
lightning and man so first they put this
thing to give like you can give blowjobs
like it opens your mouth up really big
and I posted that picture on Instagram
who did real well people really like and
then they put it out when they get leg
give you braces the tribe embarrassing
separate your
your lips from touching and where your
teeth are going to be then they put a
protective gel on your gum line and then
after that then they put this fucking
hydrochloric acid on your teeth to start
bleeped and then they do multiple rounds
for in an hour so the first round went
by and my so uh I had my thing I had two
headphone there was a scene to a podcast
then I go fucker second round I start to
do I go like this to wipe something on
my lip and my my finger touches it and
she goes you're going to burn your hand
I'm like okay so she wipes my hand well
a little bit got on my lips are burning
my lip yeah so I had to write on my
thumb my lip is burning and then she
took a cloth and she wiped my lip by the
third round I was definitely feeling
burning in my gums yeah and a little bit
on my tongue oh god the work she did
last thing where she sprayed into the
gum line yeah and then sucked it out
right away yeah yeah that helps but
after that final round I was like what
is burning pretty bad you know how I
it's man that night I had a shooting
pains in my teeth yeah yeah well you're
burning enamel the layers of enamel off
your teeth but it is worth it
it is all worth it I mean your teeth
look so much better now I'm so happy for
you they're not buttery yellow again
people don't really see your teeth a lot
because you don't smile much because
you're not a good personality you don't
have a good personality so I don't know
if it's totally lost money right yeah
but it's good it's there let the teeth
are white appreciate you appreciate you
appreciate your thoughts it's been nice
for looking at you I better do that yeah
yeah but it is yeah you're so mean to
your parents yeah your highs like can I
pay for you guys to do it please oh yeah
yeah sure I wanted to do you think your
dad would do it your dad needs it yeah
can they treat dad mouth like if you
were to go I don't know I mean I I don't
know if they would actually treat him
because I remember when she said we're
going to your tight
teeth whitening I actually go show me
your teeth and she held up like this all
these little teeth on a I guess on
what's it called on a thing right uh
like a stick yeah yeah it's to see all
the different shades that your teeth
aren't going to be and she goes okay
you're in this shade it she goes you're
lucky it's um yellow and not gray she
goes if it's gray this won't work she
goes with yellow like a yellow hue ready
can you can left the color she goes gray
we can't do it interesting so you're
saying that your dad's gray I think a
lot of old people are gray yeah right
yeah it's rotten and that that's
probably what it adds to the dad mouth
is the grayness of the teeth it's
probably the bacteria the dying decaying
teeth in your head or making your mouth
stink bad yeah yeah Lots and your gums
are probably old and stinky too it's
just probably the age of your mouth that
makes you yeah I have to get dad mouth
and just what kind of maintenance are
you doing like anything else are you
taking care of it to maintain you gotta
maintain yeah yeah well I don't think
your dad's losses would you say that he
flosses no no never no and probably
reluctantly goes you know to get things
done like roulette yeah teeth and gum
care I'm sure it's really like God I go
there again I went last year and oh you
didn't well I went two years ago like
that Mia did your mom floss mm-hmm I'm
sure she doesn't yeah that's my guess I
don't know maybe like it she's the kind
it's like oh this is annoying I just had
corn is bothering me let's get it out
most people are like that I say that's
when most people floss right that's but
that's the only time I I haven't seen
her me like oh I gotta floss and going
to bed my sisters are actually really
good at dental care well yeah
Jane's got great teeth yeah and write
email all ways remember Maria like
flossing oh he's got great teeth too yep
very hi Jose who are good at it but the
folks not so much guys my name is Daniel
quality and I'm a cat consultant
I guess they'd buy the 500 individual
clients and their cats so this asshole
rate gets better today we visited bill
they'll have three cats one is urinating
on bill while he was sleeping she
initially surrendered to my bike and
asked the cat permission for what he
wants what that's the kind of advice is
hold on if your cat is fucking pissing
on you or your dog
yeah I'd say that's a sign of severe
prot behavioral on to the cat the cat
does not respect you this guy doesn't
care this way he thinks wait till you
hear the language you use I teach human
client could benefit I am it's the voice
of love cats are trying to tell and
people love them I am I'm the voice you
know is this a fundamental difference
the divide if you will between cat and
dog people is that the cat people are oh
I thought you were to talk about how
we're on the brink of civil war in this
country but what do you say no no the
very important stuff I'll talk about
that a very important divide between cat
and dog people is that people who love
cats really love being treated poorly
and they they see themselves as
submissive to the cats dog people are we
I don't think where is that that way no
you yesterday dominant that's what he
said yeah he wasn't his human clients to
be better to be better slaves right
because in cat I'm saying my best
friend's a cat person and she's always
talking about you know the cats being a
jerk and but they they are submissive to
the cat's needs right it's different in
the dog world you have to lay back you
know where the dominant you have to be
dominant you have to otherwise the dog
they have free reign and it's not
healthy for they actually don't like it
right I'm just saying it's two different
world I'm not a judge in control they
need rules and boundaries and guidelines
yeah cats
set the tone of the house and then you
they're free room yeah and yeah if I
think it's harder to discipline a cat
how do you even I've had cats growing up
you don't you just don't right they just
do what they do and you adapt yeah exact
they fuck up your house and piss on you
while you sleep anyways you're just like
well that's what mckiddy does he finally
asks for permission
so wait so please sir you know walk me
through this is there more oh there's
more I love it
my concentration is finding out what's
going on with the cat to not only
understand the body language but the
emotions okay oh there's your favorite
what they were saying right there oh
that's some good stuff right there
he's my see my favorite would be he goes
right see he's um he's upset about when
you leave without telling him and then I
go yeah um I think he's happy right here
yes and then he goes now he's not how do
you know that how do you not know that
what you're interpreting is his acting
out or anxiety isn't his joy did the
entire did you read his diary babe when
he went to bed hey but he has tattoos of
cat on his body he wears cat apparel the
guy is an expert okay sure my experience
comes from working in the animal shelter
system here see it's hard work job
because I love people out and I love cat
all right no wonder if he knows our
friend that also works in the animals
and probably should ask her yes like hey
did you know this clown that does a cat
consulting well my friend also loves
cats
- she might they might be a match made
in heaven they might be perfect for you
and you can learn a lot local front cap
they live moments in Roman and next here
we go I'd say all dog was there stupid
here's their emotions I'm happy to see
you
I'm getting upset let's be best friends
I'm interested I'm crazy about you
feeling loving I'm worried cats in the
world
cat sure live moment to moment and I
think that's what a lot of people don't
really do yeah live in the meow oh
that's cute cats live in them yeah I
love that of course you know they live
with them meow
yeah all right now right yeah press
pause hey do you think we're gonna get a
cat soon to be fun oh come on you want
to be an out
I'm not against it as a species but I'm
allergic to them and they would suck
yeah I like heaven cat around cats are
fun what is this person let's say catch
everything I know too much about my dad
preferences with all the talk of Tom not
wanting to know what gets top dog hard I
can top that guy after my dad's second
marriage ended
we lived together just the two of us
eventually we got fairly comfortable
with each other and he started dating
again one night he came home from a date
I asked him the usual so how'd it go
he smiled and then proceeded to shove
two of his fingers he just used to stir
his day paint up to my nose oh wow now
she's my stepmom keep it high and tight
storm and nasties hit oh fuck storm that
could be a guy or a girl
hope it's a guy perfect show for this
yeah that's really I don't know why
parents don't understand that even
though they're adult the child being an
adult as well yeah we don't want to know
things about your life I have a friend
nemu is living with his dad yeah and his
dad fucks yeah door opens yeah oh yes he
told me about this and then he was like
dad leave me shut the door when you fuck
your girlfriend and he was like your
dogs in here he said the dog will just
nervous if I shut the door sure it's
like I don't care man I don't want to
hear you fucked
don't you love because I was just like
what is your what's your problem what
are the dads are narcissists who don't
think about the children's feelings or
anything right why should your friend
have a right to say anything but don't
you love when people have lame excuses
for stuff like that let out the dog no
calendar I have to traumatize my son by
fucking in front of him yeah wish I
could close the door I do the dog I'm
inside of the dog you asshole you're
just an asshole the dog is the p1
fucking that we only get out stupidest
reason I know another email came in do
blind people dream they said if so do
they dream and picture
or smells or touches day I should see
that's a good question to you well I
don't know I feel like it's obvious as
they dream they dream but do they dream
the same way that sighted people do
because we see things like how do they
see in our minds eye well they have a
vivid imagination right yeah yeah I
don't know if you're blind can you tell
I mean but here's the thing what you
described would it be you know I mean
how do they know that they're seeing
things differently than we do in our
minds I they don't know unless you've
been had your sight and then lost right
or if you were born your I know you how
do they know how do we you how do we
know it's just fucking Ellison your
dreams are like fucking psychedelic I
love it
no I just want to know how you would
describe what you see in your dreams oh
here's an email that came in about
playing against disabled kids last thing
I talked about in football when we beat
a deaf school
it said hearing you talk about playing
the deaf because the football sparked my
classic memories from childhood I'm from
Indiana where basketball is life and in
grade school I was playing against a
team that had a kid with a nub for a
left arm I had two apprehensively guard
him and immediately wanted to jump off a
building when my super intense
competitive dad yells from the stands
make him go left for the whole gym to
hear my god classic just thought I would
share thanks for the most entertaining
palm cast out there
you make my 10-hour workday go quickly
keeping it a night buh-bye oh yeah I
remember playing in those Little League
games against a few nubs - yeah there's
always a little rec league teams they
always had like a kid you know missing a
hand or some in back yeah there was some
drug in the 50s I think that mothers
were taking I had a teacher in college
who had the baby arm yeah it was from
some drugs they gave her mom in football
by the way I saw I've seen it on the
news I'm sure people have seen this on
the news there's this clip or you know
with social media it's made its rounds
these days of this guy who played in
high school game with no lakes Wow
so he's just like he has little nub legs
and he would waddle out there
and actually play football how did he
did he have like a machine like a
wheelchair apparatus no seriously he was
just on whatever legs did I think he had
like like half arms full arms either and
so he would play on the line and they
would you know he just go out it was I
mean that was amazing to see that this
kid wanted to do that that badly yeah
dude well there's a will there's a way
yeah and I guess now to a technology
they can you know maybe you can build
things to help yeah well I don't think
you could do that and now that this
video case but I'm saying like other
stuff yeah yeah well that's pretty nice
noise um what's it called nice and you
want to burp of vomit no please I don't
want to hear this topic my girlfriend
Diane and I were intrigued by a new
vocabulary when you try to shit but only
a fart my favorite is in poster which is
a good one and in booster yes I like
that one a lot
while we were hugging ourselves to
orgasm we were wondering why there's no
word for when you try to burp but you
act Adam that there is a word we propose
the word you're no Burke now also what
if you coffin in vomit the comet stop it
I know mommy Tina loves her vomit so it
should be helpful love John and Suzanne
now being the the emetophobia I am stop
it I know the word it is called a birth
ball a birth when you go to burp but you
vomit it is a birth and I haven't had a
birth in several years but as a child
had several births I don't know for some
reason childhood there is only you're
always pushing out burps until you'd
birth yeah that happens right yeah yeah
yeah I hated burping that was the worst
cuz I need to remember and you'd have to
take a sip of like cactus cooler Dr
Pepper oh yeah yeah babe
yeah no I know really on top of it I did
get those fingers ready yeah okay I like
it no we're not and I don't trust you
and why don't you trust me and then I
put these headphones on you're gonna
play another barf clip I don't know you
I won't I won't
you look so much like Robin Williams
response you always say that
more like patch Adams though I don't
know why I don't look like patch Adam oh
well I do I knew it I can fucking hear
it
[Music]
you're the worst yeah I'm not going to
push them stop it I can hear it on the
headphones doll okay
did I tell you the email that this girl
wrote in a while back no I'm not going
to put these on if you play barf clips
your trigger finger is hot let me see
your hands put your hands up okay
anyways there's a girl who wrote in
because she knows I'm in a meta phobe
yeah and that was called uh-huh a meta
faux a team at of Bobi a-- - ii met is
to throw up
eme T o emetophobia and she said there's
a pill you can take that will paralyze
your stomach so that you don't vomit
yeah have you taken it No did you get it
yeah you do have it well because I read
about it and like let's say you have the
stomach flu or something it's spasms of
the stomach muscle it's not necessary to
vomit I know what you're doing and I'm
not on any other songs Aniki there's
nothing okay you're like there's
something sneaky yeah no there's not you
think I'm fucking me you do dude I know
your farts in a lineup I know what
you're doing you know it's not there's
nothing over here like that there isn't
there's nothing honest like that I
promise I promise I swear this one
doesn't have it
this one doesn't it doesn't this one has
been a rock you guys are doing good
that's better better watch out I'm just
saying this one doesn't have that you
want me to touch your penis yes then
don't play anymore puke clips come on
don't ruin the fun for everybody fun you
know what's the audience likes when you
made almond look anything you know like
they message me about it top it and they
like it that's terrible they like my
suffering yeah they like it they react
it's a genuine reaction that's why they
like it they want to see genuine stuff
you know
it's worse okay here I'm shutting it
down you're not yes I lost all my trust
babe that one was an accident I didn't
mean to do that
so didn't mean to I'm sorry about that
so babe it's over now no it's not your
line no it's over it is over it is over
you wanna see this woman get really
excited about eating an ice cream sundae
I guess a new Sunday came out she got
barf a nap now she doesn't barf it up
but she gets really excited and she's
alone she's just like god damn this
fucking tastes good it's like I mean
here look there's no one there
and crazy it's a bacon sundae oh boy
I like how she matched her shirt to the
decor of that rest was pretty cool
purple on purple there's a lot of things
going on there I like the cheese bed to
be honest she should be eating that no
she should not be having the Sunday the
bacon Sunday calories no she's retired
you don't share dairy
[Music]
hey freeze over he's very theatrical
I think that's my new favorite that
happened you're like I'm gonna
appreciate that clip a lot the next time
I see it yeah I feel like I like a lot
already
oh I felt that way before like you know
when you've been alone and you felt that
way yes when you're yang especially with
food yeah it was one of those things
really sometimes you go like especially
if you're alone and doesn't want to be
like you got Travis I know and I have
been several times yeah yes I wanted to
do the exact same thing you everyone do
this horrible hard it's LA yeah that's
la for you thinking about moving to LA I
mean Jesus that's one of the things you
can run into here in Los Angeles after
dinner huh
something I got some water for you
things all right well for her just kind
of reminds me a little bit of bubbly my
man yeah it's not female it's what I do
want to address you thought huh so I'm
gonna show you
I don't know them yet that's so weird
yeah that was a girl
fuck me of my eyes man I love them whoa
what is howling dishes smashing the car
[Laughter]
yeah I let on people clown on can we
hear the homeless guy but we my man -
good one yeah man pleasantly you
fuckless feel good
so hopefully fucking me
lovely my my shit shit shit what you
made it man
that guy really does it and one of the
Kent homeless coma homeless guy gets
raped by Daigo yeah actually they got
taken down from a lot of places oh I
think both for its title and content yes
it because the title was homeless man
raped by geckos this is really February
that's why I live alone yeah yeah it
didn't actually sorry she just so you
know the lady we just played is laying
on the hood of a car saying fuck you
Jesus and fuck me Jesus and pretending
to be fucked and humping the car giving
a blowjob today blood yeah why we're
just mocking people that need help right
now
fuck me David yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty
good
okay there's anything else you need
Jeanne anything else I think I got it
all in this episode yeah boy mmm what
did Jesus um
yeah thank you guys as always for
listening to the show and we'll be back
soon with another episode and we might
have a guest in here next time and we'll
be looking forward to seeing you at the
live shows coming up and on the road of
course as we keep touring Oh this uh
listen to this right away this Friday
I'm doing a Joe Rogan episode 1000 the
NamUs is that a thousand that's so crazy
game it's myself and Jose Coco Diaz and
Joe and then that night we're going to
do a celebration show at The Comedy
Store super fun that's going to be a lot
of fun that's a big show you guys should
get your tickets I don't know if it's
all that it's all about only three
minutes that's crazy
but the podcast will be fundable palm
casts the palm cast will be very fun to
listen to so check it out and again
thank you for listening we'll see you
next time
by Jane here's the rub rub song by DJ
boy butter
thanks mommy's fellow Americans industry
is happy as well in the country and that
is where all the
[Music]
how often like you with it
maybe there is
[Music]